to present the award for outstanding
directorial achievement the director's
dream a dream of a director with five
oscars of his own here are ali mcgraw
and francis coppola
in america he's called the director
but in other countries he has a
different name
the french call them realization
italians call him register
it translates the realizer the one who
realizes the dream
actually uh whatever you call it the job
is to to
make dreams come true so that audiences
can
see them and hear them and be part of
them
you know i
i'd like to say that i i think that
we're on the eve of something that's
going to make the industrial revolution
look like a
small town tryout out of town and i'm
i'm talking about the communications
revolution i think it's coming very
quickly and that the the movies of the
80s are going to be amazing beyond what
any of you can dream just a couple years
away from now and i can
i see
i see a communications revolution that
is about movies and art
and music and digital electronics and
computers
and satellites and above all human
talent
and it's going to make things that the
masters of the cinema who from whom
we've inherited this business wouldn't
believe the things that are going to be
possible
and in the spirit of this wonderful new
cinema of the future we're very very
honored
to announce the nominees for the best
director of 1979
pal ashby for coming home
michael cimino for the deer hunter
warren beatty and buck henry for heaven
can wait
woody allen for interiors
alan parker from midnight express
the winner
francis you're the is
my colleague in paisan mike lucimino for
the deer hunter
at a moment like this it's
difficult to
leven pride with humility
but i am
proud to be here
and proud of our work
proud to be part of this tradition
i'm proud of my
dear
very special associates
joanne corelli
barry spikings
chris watkin
john savage
meryl streep
the late john casale
and most especially
i embrace robert de niro
for his
dedication
and for his great dignity of heart thank
you very much
ladies and gentlemen last year at the
50th anniversary presentation of the
academy awards
an american institution stood on this
stage and said some very heartfelt words
about another american institution
tonight we'd like to relive that moment
with you
before we get to the big one this is a
word to one of hollywood's biggest
he's in boston right now and we want you
to know duke we miss you tonight
we expect to see you handle out here in
person next year because nobody else can
walk in john wayne's boots
ladies and gentlemen
mr john wayne
thank you
thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen
that's
just about the only medicine
fella i'd ever really need
believe me when i tell you that i'm
mighty pleased that i can't amble down
here tonight
well oscar and i have something in
common
oscar first came to
the hollywood scene in 1928.
so did i
we're both
a little weather beaten but
we're still here and
planned to be around for a whole lot
longer
my job here tonight is to identify your
five choices for outstanding picture of
the year
and announce the winner
so let's move them out
the first nominated film
is about two very different survivors
of the vietnam war
and the woman who served
shared their survival
coming home
a jerome
hellman enterprise production united
artist
jerome hellman producer
the next the story of search for meaning
of comradeship
and for the meaning of the war in which
it occurred
the deer hunter
an emi
film michael
cimino film production universal
barry spikings michael dealey michael
cipino cimino
and john peverall are the producers
a fantasy of afterlife that has a great
deal to say about
reality of our present day world
heaven can wait dogwood productions
paramount
warner beatty producer
a story of the capacity for human
endurance
under subhuman conditions
a foreign prison system midnight express
a casablanca film works production
columbia alan marshall and david putman
producer
the story of the end of a marriage in
the beginning of life
an unmarried woman
a 20th century production
fox 20th century
paul mazurki and tony ray producers
and the winner is
the deer hunter
one more
i love you madly
thank you
thank you to all the people who made the
movie and thank you very much for your
kindness and generosity
i can only add to that
thanks to two people one who helped us
in the beginning who was bobby litman
and one who helped us towards the end
when we started the production which is
harry upland thank you very much
duke there is absolutely no way that we
can follow your appearance here tonight
except to say that we have a lot of
friends of yours backstage who want to
say hello
so ladies and gentlemen thank you good
night
for the 51st annual academy awards show
this is john harland speaking
three great shows make great viewing
wednesday on abc first it's the
fun-filled new family show the mckenzies
of paradise cove this week a mysterious
gift brings the mckenzie kids an
unforgettable surprise then death stalks
the angels in a haunted mansion on
charlie's angels right after hal linden
takes a hilarious look at tv stardom
with guest stars catherine damon of
sophony franklin and one day at a time
analysis linda label all wednesday night
starting at eight seven several mountain
on abc
you